well the issue around the 13.4 million
is uh the figure that uh the department
of transport have uh determined uh in
connection with the forced major claim
as to why there was so much
inconvenience to passengers last year so
uh in good faith and with good grace um
you know that is our proportion and we
are you know dipping into our pockets to
pay that to get more passenger benefits
back into the system but uh also we need
to take cognizance of the fact that the
gibb report the independently uh uh
produced report last week uh by chris
gibb identified that the problems of
disruption are clearly laid at the trade
union's door and we're seeing that again
today so the company will stand up to
its responsibilities we will move
forward we're glad that we've drawn a
line under this with the department for
transport and we move on to continue to
modernize this part of the railway which
is what gtr was set up for in the first
place this isn't entirely the fault of
the union so otherwise the government
wouldn't be finding you the fine clearly
reflects the fact that they say you have
contributed to the problems yes i mean
there's there's no doubt that we have
our own shortcomings and we're sorry
about those but this is drawing a line
under those so we're making these
investments in further improvements to
performance further reinforcement of
staffing in some key areas not least the
onboard service supervisors who've
proved so successful with the changes
that the company's made in the last
eight months so we're looking to move
forward as part of the modernization
this rail network has grown it's doubled
in size in passenger numbers in the last
12 years almost twice as fast as the
rest of the uk rail industry so it's
important that as well as the track and
the signaling and the new trains that
passengers are seeing we improve and
modernize our working practices now
you've been quite critical of the unions
but surely bad management has a
contributory part of playing this as
well well we take our our own share of
responsibility but let's be very clear
about this the rmt have caused 33 days
of inconvenience and disruption to our
passengers and as left have done
likewise with the strikes that they've
caused and the calling today against a
pay offer of almost 24
over four years to try to bring a
conclusion to this dispute it beggars
belief uh that train drivers are
rejecting that when many of the
passengers the vast majority probably of
the passengers that we're carrying you
know couldn't dream of pay increases
like that so it is shocking and
frustrating and the way
the timing of of when those strikes are
called is is to cause maximum
inconvenience
to to passengers and minimum disruption
to train drivers and their pay packets
but why is it do you think that the
passengers to whom you've just referred
regard southerners the country's worst
rail franchise
um clearly our performance has put us at
the bottom of the league table for some
time but as i say uh the force measure
claimed that the the fine as you
describe it today draws a line under
that we've been improving our
operational performance uh for the last
seven stroke eight months so we're 23
percent improved in our operational
performance from where we were when i
joined just before christmas we want to
keep that momentum going our job is to
serve our passengers we want to do that
day in day out and our invitation to the
trade unions you know is to join us in
that and many of our staff are
thoroughly professional in the work they
do we want them to come and embrace the
new working practices which as far as
driver only operation is concerned
operates across a third of the uk
railway and
colleagues on southern have been doing
that since
january without any problem